if we were to write a training program
for Jason Bourne what would it look like
well I'd start with cardio if he needs
to chase a suspect he needs to be able
to do so without getting gassed out
strength endurance goes hand in hand
with this whether carrying equipment
wrestling an opponent swimming or
climbing strength endurance is often
more important than max strength some
form of combat training would be a must
although this is less of a focus for
Intelligence Officers than you might
think so what is a focus well he'd need
soft skills that means persuasion
Charisma couple that with situational
awareness psychomotive vigilance that's
the ability to stay focused and alert
even under stress and fatigue maybe some
agility and a little bit of basic
parkour should be up there and of course
he needs good aim
how useful are all of these things for
you and me to train though when will we
ever need to chase someone down a
crowded Street and fight them in an
Alleyway but then again when do you ever
need to bench press 150 kilograms do the
training that makes you feel awesome
bye for now